[Music]
in Canadian street justice news oh [ __ ]
are they gonna be like oh I'm sorry no
don't be sorry you be sorry they give
each other gifts after submitted by
Joe's tiny eyeballs no you know not that
one the other way
yeah that's God I got little eyes
Canadian Hells Angels are getting their
street justice by attacking through
Facebook and yo that sounds like an
oxymoron - I know
Canadian telling street justice online
you know what's crazy
the Hells Angels are incorporated in
their worldwide why and they have a
lawyer really yeah I know they're
international but I thought they would
avoid Canada because it's too nice there
I'm surprising today so a president of
the Manitoba Nomad uh which is a chapter
of Hells Angels yeah when he heard that
one of his members was turn away from a
hotel because of him wearing the
trademark logos he immediately went on
Facebook and called on everybody to
boycott the business and to give them
one star reviews OSHA's dude his name is
Dale Callen oh [ __ ] businesses that
don't support motorcycle clubs and their
supporters here's another one
Mary shittiest bar and Winnipeg like I
think it's [ __ ] love that they went
to Photoshop first yeah yeah and also
this is a great font most people are
just good for these ello
what the all right this bar in Winnipeg
discriminates against bikers and their
supporters all independent bikers MCS
are seized and all riding groups should
boycott boycott bit smelly cracks you
say boy [ __ ] yeah I did okay
smelly crack shack comment if you'd
never go to this [ __ ] and then they
put a little poop emoji which i think is
very important that's cute
like and share if you agree and hate
people who discriminate against bikers
with [ __ ] Marriott Hotel Winnipeg
that's pretty funny
um yeah that's so weird as a business
person if if a guy comes up right name
is like Roy right Road close I got me a
muffled good there you guys I need some
room like 30 people [ __ ] yeah you know
yeah cuz they're coming with everybody
to [ __ ] book my rooms yeah as long as
you don't trash I'll give a [ __ ] what
you are dude yeah I feel like the hotel
owner was an Indian or Chinese yep
because I feel like they were fired you
know what any business is good business
yeah me and my pedophile friends gonna
come in but are you going to pace the
question hey hey hey don't get personal
with me we're not friends give me the
money house angels were hard I think
they are [ __ ] hard as [ __ ] dude
doesn't mean they can't be tech savvy
yeah I didn't say that hoes angels are
hard yeah good luck with that deal
whoopee oh I saw some gangland stuff
about them and I was like oh yeah
dangerous but maybe not this chapter
this particular baby hey they have
different ways of handling business you
know like maybe their I heard that
they're smart or not like organized
crime mmm like we're gonna mess up their
business by doing things the yup way or
something yeah but y'all pass protection
against that now if you have a business
that like gets targeted by something
online they actually have an option
where you can like send an email to
support and like link whoever's
targeting you and they'll get rid of all
those one-star reviews that [ __ ] don't
work anymore y'all I tried yeah they
were commenting that on on this one like
there are certain people saying like oh
it seems like they're blocking new
reviews but yeah so here's another post
play someone else named Andy by request
of a member please show this business
what happens when you discriminate
against law-abiding motorcycle clubs and
supporters give the one start and leave
your review and I'm saying uh support 81
which means eight is the hh8 yeah so
it's a eighth letter document exactly no
I mean that's a lot of gangs through
that kind of stuff yeah so they're
saying that within 24 hours there were
hundreds of people that
giving one-star reviews and most of them
outside of Canada and it's on the rest
on the restaurants Facebook page of
reduced to the rating from 4.5 stars to
three stars that's pretty bad yeah it
led them to the point of taking down to
the Facebook page of the hotel and
that's when everyone started directing
the one-star reviews to the restaurant
that's inside of the hotel that's mean
oh yeah the restaurant didn't say no you
didn't do anything what do you want to
do to join the Hells Angels you just hit
join on the Facebook group or do you
have to like actually get an issue I
don't know typical motorcycle gangs you
have to be like a prospect for like a
year you have to dinner like pretty much
their [ __ ] and in turn you have to do a
bunch of crazy [ __ ] that's what I always
thought stuff is like but I mean like
2018 gangs like what if like what if I
just went on a page joined it and I was
posting regularly for like a few months
and then they're like oh yeah she's cool
like you know like is that how it works
now Oh like you're a part of the cyber
gang Department yeah so like you're like
not violent but you like [ __ ] for them
online and you don't even you don't even
my motorcycle like I'm somebody's maybe
that she reminded me of like college I
remember like my freshman year you know
that where they try to get you to join
like frats and [ __ ] yeah and they're
like okay one the first slide you have
an initiation phase I was like you're
not a gang why the [ __ ] do I got to get
in this year I'm money you make
sandwiches and do they make you like do
beer runs they make you do all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm like but I gotta
pay you to be in this it doesn't look
you mean you're not a [ __ ] gang dude
like what the [ __ ] I do in the [ __ ] or
the crazy engine goes to their Clubhouse
or costs and stuff but I think the
benefit is the when you realize when you
are Lum night right like you get hooked
up with the other guys and Rishabh yeah
this is part of the initiation you get
built into the network and then you meet
another guy from like kappa zap adapt or
whatever that's from liking like the
east coast like hey i need a job and
then they're like alpha alpha alpha god
say potato over crop yeah
albatross albatross turtleneck I think
everybody needs to feel like they belong
and they're a part of like a movement or
there's something you know it's fun when
I was in high school I did the whole god
thing for like eight years someone else
dawn I think the god thing because like
I was like I'm like Mick so like the
black kids didn't wanna be my friend and
the white kids in wanna be my friend so
I was like alright whatever I'm gonna go
shop at Hot Topic I'm not my own
subculture look like you straight up I
could tell I could see you with like the
[ __ ] the meat tenderizers on your
wrist is your meat tender that's right I
sure did
for a while I had my Avril Lavigne tie
and then I moved on to the black cargo
pants and the corn t-shirt I could legit
picked you ain't see it really even like
brace on really oh I still yeah I still
have damages and piercings that's it
yeah that makes sense yeah yeah you know
I googled how to get into angels did you
really did and there's this application
please no so the first thing is they're
saying that if you're googling how to
get into Hell's Angels you probably
won't be joining them yeah yeah then
they do go into like the prerequisites
you need to have a Harley Davidson
motorcycle hey they're like you wouldn't
get in but since you're and then you
will write a lot okay like a lot about
what it you will be right it's our IDE
there's a twenty page as they do know it
says that you will be expected to live
on your Harley Davidson writing across
cities and states on your way to meet oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you have an um cream uh
ch yeah yeah and then the club comes
first this is your new life a bully
patch member will have voting rights how
do they work and make money
a lot of illegal okay that's pretty cool
running gun running low understand
there's four phases of a membership the
first phase is the hang around the
second is the associate the third is the
prospect and the fourth is a fully
patched no this is too much work dude
Wow this prospect is like the third huh
I just want a world up and they get
jumped and I'm pretty much in that's too
much work no it takes time I've read
like this undercover article or this guy
he was like a FBI agent who's trying to
infiltrate the Hells Angels and it took
him like four years to finally become a
member you have to get it tattooed on
his body like do all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
just to get in to really prove that he's
not a Fed and he's gonna get into the
game but he was a Fed but he was a
federally recognized gang right yo did
you all know that
Juggalos are considered a federally
recognized gang a juggle around an ICP
fan it is considered a federally
recognized game that is crazy they're
not even like one group they're just
like fans that are yeah it's considered
it's like saying gothic gang like
everyone whose [ __ ] is good yes they
don't make sense also I looked it up
pretty recently and like you know how
they list gang affiliates the Juggalos
affiliates it literally said bloods
Crips Ku Klux Klan and then it just kept
going and I was like how are y'all oh is
that on Wikipedia when they show them
like but you and then you pick one like
I understand I wouldn't even be able to
do an episode on Juggalos cuz it's like
that doesn't even make sense I would
watch it have you ever seen the drug
alone documentary by roaming around
every single circus in every state times
when their makeup doesn't mesh they get
angry what the [ __ ] my powder I don't
know where's my bag oh when the [ __ ] is
that
it's a soda that they drink oh they all
drink the same type of soda that's a
thing what there you go Fago
this is a pixelated but yeah they go oh
a nice so it's like Fanta right where do
they sell it like a Midwest Walmart 25
cent drink thing it's it's like a thing
man that where I grew up there was a lot
of Juggalos I used to love the Shasta
Cola machines because they were way
cheaper than the regular soda 25 oh man
she was dull I was so hype 20 I get for
[ __ ] cans of soda but one dollar oh
my god there's a picture of them
drinking you Juggalos yeah dude yeah did
you look up Juggalos okay go no I just
it was there when I googled they all
have that's how ICP stays relevant in
the world they think they're talking
they're trolling dude no no look of
Juggalos and Faygo like I think I don't
think those are real Juggalos I think
that picture is like buzzer - pretending
yeah dude the title it's really been a
go flavors ranked by Juggalos last time
joke's on you why'd you get attacked me
laughing that's because all right Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]